sieben jahre lang verkörperte der
wahl-schweizer ostermayer im bestatter
den wiener alois semmelweis schön dass
sie da sind
ein gespräch mit diesem jahr hat sich
etwas totgelaufen einen bleichgesichtige
zynischen besserwisser kommissarin
giovanoli gespielt von barbara tatorten
und mike müller als bestatter der den
ermittlern ins handwerk pfuscht unter
die arme griff hatten mit semmelweis
manchmal ihre liebe mühe
seine sprüche waren alles andere als
leichte kost im supermarkt bei 3.000
punkten gibt es einen suppentopf gratis
die sprüche wurden allerdings kult und
ostermayer der heimliche
publikumsliebling der in der rolle des
wieners mit hang zum morbiden offenbar
voll und ganz aufgeht
daraus wird dann schauen wir mal was
macht einfach scheußlich es finden
da gab es zum beispiel einmal eine eine
leiche in einer metzgerei die dadurch zu
tode gekommen ist dass sie mit dem kopf
im fleisch brät steckte und erstickt ist
[Musik]
ein schweine zahn
und so sagt
da hat die maske ganze arbeit geleistet
also wie sah zwar relativ ähnlich aus
hier ist vom orkan gewebe der lunge hier
kaum mehr zu unterscheiden ist kein
grund techniker darin zu werden meine
leben das war ganz mag aber lustig das
zu drehen das hat spaß gemacht
das wäre es der sich in den abend statt
da das servus
ihre rolle ist für sehr viel werbung für
ironie projekt sie aber beim rolle
studium ganz mal von hand sie erreicht
hätten so buck klasse sind das papier
mitgebracht zum beispiel für michael
tsokos leiter der rechtsmedizin der
charité berlin er beschreibt realität
immer lustig was hat sie hat eine
geschichte fasziniert also fasziniert
ich habe erfahren was alles möglich ist
soll man setzt auf einen auf einen satz
gebracht
der michael tsokos schreibt im vorwort
von dem buch das er die schlimmsten
fälle nicht aufgeschrieben hat weil sie
quasi dem publikum nicht zumuten will
es gibt aber in dem buch immer noch
einige fälle die einem wirklich das blut
in den adern gefrieren lassen muss ich
sagen also mir ging es so es ist nicht
so dass mich das dann verfolgt dass ich
dann deswegen nicht mehr schlafen kann
aber es erweitert ein bisschen das
menschenbild ja in der hinsicht dass man
sagt okay was man sich einfallen lassen
kann
das macht irgendwann auch irgendjemand
irgendwo auf dieser welt ich simon
beckett zum jahresthema kannte ich bis
jetzt nicht hab ich gerade davon gehört
und scheint mir ein interessanter auto
zu sein
hier sticht aus der masse der thriller
autoren heraus